agent kister was running for his life
every breath had burned in his throat
like inhaling chlorine gas he sped
through the dark surrounded by deafening
metallic screams that bounced off the
eternity of pipes scaling and strangling
the walls around him as far as he was
concerned this was what hell looked like
a nightmare boiler room that would
somehow be less scary if freddy krueger
was there because at least there'd be
some kind of recognizably human
intelligence to reason with the pipes
scp-015
are truly unknowable as an scp
foundation mobile task force member
agent kister had seen some truly
horrific things in the line of duty he'd
been there during scp-682 containment
breaches firing an assault rifle at the
beast as its scales hardened into a
bulletproof carapace he'd seen the femur
breaker used on some poor godforsaken
d-class to lure uncle larry back into
the containment chamber for some
midnight fun in the most
anxiety-inducing mission of his life he
once even bagged 096's weeping face
after it slaughtered a whole mountain
village and these damn pipes were going
to be the thing that killed him he
turned a sharp corner trying to block
out the screams of his teammates four of
them had been sent in the rest were
already dead or worse
stupid stupid stupid they'd made a
classic military mistake underestimating
the capabilities of their enemy and in
agent kister's experience this had
always been a capital offense all to
install that machine that stupid little
remote control reconnaissance vehicle
that's what they'd given their lives for
agent kister tried to blink away the
memory of agent montgomery's face monty
was the youngest member of the team 28
years old his first major mission into
the heart of a skip kister wanted to
remember him how he'd first seen him a
bright-eyed green horn ready to protect
the human race from the horrors that lay
in the dark but he'd been the first to
go when everything got f-u-b-a-r
it was the smaller pipes that got monty
four of them shot out spearing his lungs
and heart pinning him in place even if
they tried to cut him out he would have
been a goner he coughed up blood and
went ghost white faster than you'd ever
imagined kister would never forget for
what little time he had left to live the
horrible sight of the light leaving that
kid's eyes and all this because one of
them had tripped on one of the pipes on
the way out and busted it the mission
was already done what an awful pointless
way to die kister was yanked from his
aching thoughts by a sudden obstacle in
the way a huge towering pipe that looked
like a pillar of flesh covered in
bulbous staring eyes the thought crossed
his mind jesus these pipes can really be
made out of anything he looked down and
saw a series of rubber pipes slithering
towards his feet along the ground like
snakes it was time to run again but how
long could you even run for when the
very location around you wants you dead
they should have sent the mole rats for
a job like this the infinitely
reconfiguring pipes changed the layout
of the warehouse around him making
escape seem all the more unfeasible
that's when he started thinking about
the terrible thing that happened to
agent greene when 015 turned hostile
they needed to make a run for it fast it
wasn't unlike being a pathogen inside a
living body you start to make trouble
and the body's immune system is going to
come for you and one of the most common
mechanisms for a body fighting a virus
is a fever a sudden increase in
temperature that burns out the threat
the group turned and ran as the pipes
started twisting towards them agent
green panicked and began striking at the
pipes around him with his hands the
first instinct would have been to shoot
but no guns were permitted inside the
scp-015 warehouse it reacted severely to
any kind of tool being brought into its
proximity
several dead agents and researchers
could tell you all about this if they
hadn't made that same mistake but when
things were already going sideways it
left them defenseless agent green was
soon boxed in caged by a latticework of
pipes in varying sizes he tried
desperately to push them out of the way
and make an escape route but the hissing
noise was getting louder and louder as
the pipes started to turn a glowing red
all around him after all when a body
needs to deal with a hostile foreign
object it burns out the threat kister
wished he could shake the awful
high-pitched whale that agent greene
made while the heat inside his pipe cage
became unbearable it was like seeing a
human get caught inside a giant bug
zapper his skin went black and charred
and soon after the heat had risen to
such an insane degree that agent green
was reduced to little more than ash in
his pipe furnace but kister couldn't
afford to dwell he kept running vaulting
over a long ragged pipe made from
stinking human hair this terrible place
stank of motor oil mold and death but
maybe those perceptions had been colored
by the terrible things he'd seen here
there was again that awful choked
screaming coming from inside the pipes
agent boggs it was a nightmare to hear
him shriek like that boggs had been one
of the toughest men that kissed her had
ever met he mentored him back when he
first became an mtf member having boggs
on the team meant experience it meant
safety it meant that things would go
okay kister had seen vog steer down some
of the most horrifying skips imaginable
and not even flinch and yet here he was
screaming and bawling like a hurt child
in the pipes boggs was the next one to
get taken as he and kister ran through
the dark trying to find a way out they'd
passed a huge pipe made of a soft
foam-like substance a seam in the side
of the pipe had yawned open and a tangle
of writhing tentacles each one barbed
with thorns like the stem of a rose bush
they enveloped agent boggs cutting into
his weathered skin he gasped in pain
unable to scream it happened so fast
before kister even had a chance to grab
him he was pulled into the pipe and the
crevice sealed behind him and that was
when the screaming really started for
poor agent boggs kister hoped for his
sake that he would die sometime soon
shrouded in the fog of his dark thoughts
agent kister turned a corner and felt
cold hard metal suddenly collide with
his face breaking his nose with an
unpleasant crunch he'd been clotheslined
by a low pipe that hadn't been there
before and now he was laid out on his
back face humming with pain thoughts and
feelings swam he looked up into the
seemingly infinite web of pipes weaving
through the air above him he was right
earlier he just knew it the place was
hell it'd be his eternal resting place
suddenly a new huge shape moved into the
space above him a pipe of ancient rusty
iron that looked older than even the
warehouse holding this whole mess right
above him there was a huge valve fixed
into the pipe's belly he watched
helpless as the valve opened itself with
a squeal and a huge dark mask came
pouring out of it onto his body a sudden
weight a sudden warmth sound and
movement and tiny scratching claws
rats thousands of big hungry black rats
with gnarled yellow teeth clumps of fur
purged from their skin by mange big
ropey worm-like tails swaying and
whipping at the air who knows how long
they've been in that pipe who knows when
these rats had eaten anything that
wasn't their brothers and sisters and
here was agent kister given unto them by
the glorious pipes the last thing he
ever saw were those nasty yellow teeth
because they ate his eyes first where do
the four disappeared and presumed dead
operatives soon reached dr charles ogden
gears the legendarily tact-turned senior
researcher that managed the
scp-015 project among a myriad of others
his face didn't betray a flicker of
emotion when he was informed about the
men lost to scp-015
it wasn't that he didn't feel for them
more that he deemed it both unproductive
and unprofessional to dwell on the
deaths of personnel when carrying out
their duties after all being killed by
an anomaly was simply an occupational
hazard and a generous stipend would be
sent to their families to compensate for
their tragic loss dr gears simply asked
was the mission successful in spite of
the casualties did the team manage to
install the modular robotic vehicle at
the epicenter he was told that the mrv
had been successfully installed at least
dr gears nodded and began scheduling a
second exploratory mission for a few
months in the future to check the status
of the machine still in the meantime the
mrv would chug along doing what humans
couldn't or perhaps shouldn't do within
the nightmarish mess of ever-growing
pipes it would roll through collecting
information on everything around it
hopefully giving the scp foundation an
in-road to mapping the whole thing
without needing to send a cavocate of
staff into the danger zone just to
discover more about these peculiar pipes
sure some lives were lost getting in
there but this measure would likely save
even more lives in the long run that was
until something went wrong the exact
nature of what happened to the mrv
inside the domain of pipes was a mystery
but it wasn't doing its intended job and
the scp foundation needed to find out
why the second exploratory mission was
required much sooner than they'd
initially anticipated with a dual
purpose collecting the readings and
finding out what exactly had happened to
the mrv in the first place he included a
more specific set of instructions for
the next mission only three members of
personnel to enter
scp-015 this time to minimize potential
loss one trained technician to collect
and read the diagnostics and two guards
to maintain discipline and safety under
pressure with a setup like that what
could possibly go wrong dr gears various
assistants began headhunting the perfect
team for the job junior researcher lon
wanting to prove herself and climb up
the ranks put her name forward she was
young intelligent and had the initiative
to get the job done though there was one
thing that she hadn't disclosed when she
was applying for this important new
position junior researcher lon suffered
from claustrophobia the fear of enclosed
spaces then the hunt was on for the two
members of foundation military personnel
who'd escort lawn to the mrv to take the
readings like the two priests in the
exorcist they decided to recruit one
grizzled experienced operative and one
extremely cautious young buck straight
out of the foundation mtf training
academy the younger of the two
operatives codenamed agent two was
careful and consensus to a fault he did
things by the book or not at all the
older operative codenamed agent 6 was
quite the opposite he done this job long
enough to operate solely on instinct and
resented his employers for expecting him
to approach his missions any other way
long agent 2 and agent 6 the team was
assembled when the time came they were
taken to
scp-015 to execute their mission it
should have been simple enough
get in collect the readings and get that
count though a few weeks earlier the
same thing would have been said for the
mission to install the mrv which left
for mobile task force operatives dead or
worse nothing was ever as simple as it
seemed when it came to scp-015
they were only allowed flashlights
inside anything else carried a
substantial risk of activating scp-015's
defensive state putting all of their
lives in jeopardy vaughn had tried to
keep things light masking her own
terrible fear of this strange new
situation she joked that perhaps the
three of them should get mario hats
seeing as they were plumbers now agent 2
happily laughed along suggesting that
perhaps he should be luigi agent six was
utterly unamused by this whole situation
and wanted no part of it which is
honestly just so wario of him they
followed along a carefully mapped route
through the pipes being careful not to
touch any of them after all you never
know what could set
scp-015 off agent 6 didn't share in
their merriment or their concern in fact
he had contempt for them and this whole
situation he thought lawn and agent 2
were a pair of frightened skittish
children willing to buy whatever
foundation assigned bull honky they were
given he didn't believe that scp-015 was
anywhere near as dangerous as they'd
been told in all likelihood knowing the
eggheads up top they just didn't want
men of action like him breaking any of
their precious little toys while
conducting missions on their behalf this
whole thing was a big stupid joke as
they ducked and weaved through the
confines of scp-015
the tensions between them all just
silently grew their flashlights played
among the pipes revealing the insane
variety of shapes sizes compositions and
materials in here wood steel flesh bone
glass pressed ash granite and so much
more and yet there were no pipes
comprised of any standard pipe making
material like lead pvc plastic or copper
it was undeniably freaky but when you
work with scps for long enough you learn
to stop asking questions about the more
minor forms of strangeness inherent to
anomalies the composition only got
narrower as they delve deeper into the
warehouse lon felt the anxiety like a
hand gripping her throat and squeezing
but tried still to keep it hidden agent
six the largest among them almost got
stuck a few times trying to crawl into
spaces too tight for him to fit he felt
like murdering lawn when she threw out a
casual comparison to winnie the pooh in
the process when they reached the mrv it
gave them an ounce of momentary relief
the journey was halfway done but the
comfort was quickly squashed by seeing
what had actually happened to the mrv it
had been speared by a pipe and new pipes
had grown through and out of it
effectively rooting it in place this
caused immediate debate among the group
around one key issue did this mean that
the mrv was now technically part of the
pipes and by extension would the pipes
feel the need to defend themselves if
the data banks were removed from the mrv
in order to deliver the readings back to
the researchers at site-17 while lawn
and agent 2 carefully discussed the
issue agent 6 lost his temper and
decided to show these two foolish kids
how it was done he claimed the two of
them were worrying about a bunch of
foundation hui that they were
inexperienced and gullible enough to
believe as if this bunch of weird pipes
was actually dangerous it was like how
every six anomalies there's apparently
one capable of ending the world it's all
a bunch of overblown fear-mongering
nonsense and to prove that he wasn't
just all talk on this front agent six
pried open the top of the mrv and slid
out the data cards which seemed to be
covered in some kind of viscous
unpleasant liquid from the pipes that
had penetrated the device still he'd
gotten what they came for he could have
done this whole thing alone without this
pair of bed wetters he scoffed and said
kids i don't know how you two survive
but he shouldn't have spoken so soon the
large pipe that he didn't even realize
he was standing on opened up beneath his
feet and seconds later he was immersed
up to his shoulders in it six began to
let out the most horrifying shrieks
you've ever heard and when agent two and
lon ran over to try and help him out
they realized why the pipe below agent 6
was filled with flowing molten iron by
the time they pulled agent 6 out well
agent 6 from the shoulders up
considering that that was all that was
left he was already dead and despite the
actual aggressor being destroyed
scp-015 wasn't done it was ready to
clean house as agent 2 and lawn
attempted to flee some eye level pipes
around them burst firing crystallized
glass into their faces cutting into
their skin and eyes but they needed to
push on despite the pain if they wanted
to survive and get out the two of them
ran horrifying noises of twisting and
bursting pipes roaring behind them pipes
made of thorns and bones started to grow
blocking off their exits until they were
trapped bond utilizing her small frame
was able to crawl through a gap in the
pipes into an adjoining chamber two was
given a horrifying surprise when a pipe
burst near his hand showering his flesh
in thick corrosive gunk his hand melted
away at the wrist as long called for
help in the tiny cramped chamber she was
locked in two ran off to try and find an
exit where he could bring more people in
to help them but it would already be too
late for poor lawn a thick honey-like
substance began bleeding into the
chamber disgusting in its overpowering
saccharine flavor and goopy viscous
thickness the chamber seemed to get
smaller and smaller as long screamed as
the honey level rose eventually it got
higher than her mouth and nose could
reach she gave a horrifying final gurgle
and then she was gone entombed forever
between the pipes agent two kept running
his flashlight was beginning to die but
he didn't care as his eyes bled from the
splinters of glass and what was left of
his hand dripped from the jagged nub of
his wrist all he could do was keep
moving forwards he panted and screamed
and stumbled in the dark until he
tripped on something he didn't notice
and pitched forwards he tumbled into the
gaping maw of a nearby pipe surrounded
by unseeable unknowable ooze as he
tumbled further down into the seemingly
infinite darkness it was too dark to see
and too cramped to move anywhere but
straight down all he could do was scream
and scream and scream until his voice
was hoarse and his throat bled though
nobody was there to even hear his cries
days later when his skin started to
shred off it was almost welcome dr gears
would later receive the news of this
tragically failed mission and the three
operatives now declared mia because of
it he sighed and wrote up his report on
the matter closing with the sentence
data deemed non-vital and might have
lost staff
scp-015 classification level review
suggested now go check out
scp-049 boiled scrambled and fried
plagued dr tail and what actually
happened to major alexi bellatrov
scp-2273 tail for more chilling tales
from the files of the scp foundation